retrouvons notre correspondant à kiev
mais l'hiver crack gulliver la
britannique 10 ce matin au 100e jour de
la guerre que les russes ont échoué à
prendre kiev et ses principaux centres
de commandement mais qu'en revanche ils
enregistrent des succès de tactique dans
le donbass est-ce que vous sur le
terrain vous partagez cette analyse
oui c'est une analyse très largement
partagé les forces ukrainienne en ce
moment sont en difficulté dans le dôme
basse mais cela est dû à la décision des
russes est concentrée la majeure partie
de leurs forces sur un front précisément
et très particulièrement sur la prise de
ce qui reste de la région de lougansk
sous contrôle ukrainienne donc les
villes de severodonetsk et de licite
chance que et ceci dit les forces
ukrainienne même si ils enregistrent des
pertes très très importante tous les
jours et c'est le président volodymyr
lui lui-même volodymyr zelensky lui même
qui le souligne ils n'ont pas ils n'ont
toujours pas cédé severodonetsk d'après
le rapport de ce matin du des militaires
ukrainiens les batailles continue dans
le centre-ville de severodonetsk et à
d'autres endroits sur la ligne de front
dans le dôme basse selon les militaires
eux craignaient des offensifs russes sur
le sol aurait été repoussée par les
ukrainiens univers au début du conflit
le crème présentait le visage d'un pays
uni face à la russie est ce que cette
unité tient pas encore
alors il ait eu un sondage publié il ya
quelques jours qui montrait que
seulement 2% des ukrainiens garder un
image favorable de la russie et que des
ukrainiens qui pourrait être considéré
comme pro-russe avant l'invasion du 24
février
80% avait changé d'avis mais après on
peut peut-être douter de la l'efficacité
de faire des sondages en temps de guerre
est ce que les gens disent vraiment la
vérité au thunder mais l'évidence
anecdotique ce que des gens nus raconte
particulièrement des déplacés qui
viennent l'est de l'ukraine on entend
très souvent des gens dire que ils ont
changé d'avis qu'ils ont ouvert les yeux
mais on entend aussi des gens parlaient
de collaborationniste de gens qui n'ont
pas changé d'avis c'était le cas par
exemple de la nasa et ses vins qui
étaient dos à dos talent et que j'ai
rencontrés dans l'ouest de l'ukraine il
ya quelques jours leurs portes à temps
j'étais à l'antenne hier elle disait que
dans le bunker avec elle sa famille
était clairement preuve craignait il y
avait une petite majorité des pros et
craignent un mais il y avait quand même
des gens dans le bunker asos talent sous
les bombes russe qui refusait de croire
que c'étaient vraiment des bombes russe
qui disait ça c'est du théâtre
anna zaitseva disait que c'est des gens
qui sont vraiment zombifiés par la
propagande russe est ce que je pense sur
quoi il faut garder un oeil c'est
comment cette propagande russe va
continuer à marcher dans les régions
d'ukraine que la russie contrôlent
actuellement et à quel point elle est
capable d'influer sur l'opinion publique
dans ces régions là les régions derrière
sol nicolas yves particulièrement dans
le dos le bass aussi je pense à cela et
si l'ukraine va passer à faire des
contre offensives on se demande comment
l'ukraine va pouvoir reprendre des
villes et des terres dans le sud de
l'ukraine sans faire des dégâts parmi la
population civile aussi et quel effet
cela va avoir sur l'opinion de ces gens
alors je pense que même si l'ukraine est
clair montrer soudés peut-être que ne
doit pas tout donner pour argent
comptant
l'adhésion de tous les ukrainiens
au patriotisme proxyav merci beaucoup
huile berck correspondant de france 24 à
kiev mais